foreign
[Applause]
ERS showing off a new do I thought it
was really brilliant really fun yeah the
26 year old chopped off her long locks
debuting a new look a short bob
it's awesome check out Haley's fresh cut
here when she was spotted out and about
in New York City and here with hubby
Justin Bieber too it's the best so with
Haley going for the blunt chop we won't
be surprised if it becomes the latest
Trend we don't really know until it's
out there in the world now we know
Haley's not shy when it comes to making
fashion statements you betcha you betcha
remember earlier this month when she
sported this nepo baby shirt that's
about it it was her not so subtle way of
addressing the narrative circling the
internet about the Privileges of famous
born children it means something to me
and of course Haley's become the go-to
gal for all things beauty and SPO like
when she gave fans tips on the hottest
new makeup hacks
[Music]
what's known as the brownie glazed lips
Trend yeah that's me last year Haley
launched her own skin care brand Road I
think of the thing about competition is
that there's space for everybody and I
really do believe that and during a wsj
Tech conference she squashed any signs
of competition with close Pals Kim
Kardashian and Kylie Jenner who also
have brands in the beauty space those
women are amazing and they're some of my
closest friends and I really love all of
their Brands and I would never not
support their brands and cheer them on
because they've also really done the
same for me in fact she doubled down
asking people to quit comparing women
and their businesses against each other
I also think that
as people in general we just struggle
with comparison so I try to be as
mindful as possible not to feel like I
am comparing myself or my brand to
anybody else's because I care so much
about the individuality of the brand so
whether it's a new hairstyle Beauty
trick or just giving plan advice we love
to see the star thriving
[Music]
foreign